congressional Democrats are pushing a
new bill requiring big changes in police
procedures throughout the US president
Trump responded on Twitter saying that
Democrats have gone crazy quote Ben
Tracy reports now on the president's
continued emphasis on law and order
there won't be defunding there won't be
dismantling of our police hosting law
enforcement representatives at the White
House Monday president Trump said the US
has the finest law enforcement in the
world
despite nationwide protests calling for
change sometimes you'll see some
horrible things like we witnessed
recently but 99 I say 99.9 but let's go
with 99 percent of them great great
people the White House has not offered
any policing reform plans and is trying
to focus attention on the protesters
were calling for defunding police
departments the Trump campaign accused
Joe Biden of supporting the cause do you
support defunding the police no I don't
support defunding the police
I support conditioning federal aid the
police based on whether or not they meet
certain basic standards of decency on
honorable listen kneel on Capitol Hill
Monday Democrats took a knee in honor of
George Floyd and then unveiled what they
called the Justice in policing Act the
proposed legislation would make it
easier to prosecute officers for
brutality create a registry to track
police misconduct and set new standards
for the use of force it does not call
for defunding the police we're here
because black Americans want to stop
being killed President Trump is turning
his focus back to the campaign CBS News
has learned that he plans to restart his
campaign rallies in the next two weeks
now the campaign knows there will be
some criticism of that given coronavirus
but they say that these large gatherings
of people for protests across the
country in recent weeks makes it harder
for Democrats to throw stones Tony
all right we'll be looking out for those
developments Ben thank you very much